[Música]
o que você quer ser quando crescer eu
aposto que todo mundo aqui em algum
momento da vida
já ouviu ou responder essa pergunta
certa mas será que o mundo com tantas
opções
a gente precisa mesmo responder essa foi
uma pergunta de uma vez por todas
eu acredito que não nós temos muitas
versões e todas elas de alguma forma
estão certas
o problema é que quando eu tinha 11 anos
eu não pensava assim
e tome a decisão escolhi o que eu queria
ser e até então eu achei que fosse pela
última vez e duas coisas influenciaram
muito a minha decisão
a minha família eo contexto em que eu
cresci na minha família eu tive e tenho
profissionais de saúde que sempre me
inspiraram
eu lembro da minha infância eu vi com
muita atenção as histórias do vovô sobre
como ele dividia o tempo dele entre o
consultório e o trabalho voluntário como
médico pediatra e um hospital para
famílias carentes
agora tudo isso colocado no contexto eu
vou pedir pra vocês então se colocar no
meu lugar agora imagina que você foi a
primeira neta o primeiro neto a surgir
nessa família esses quatro caras aqui
perguntar pra você o que você vai ser
mas não acabou por aí
os meus brinquedos eles variavam entre a
ambulância do doutor será tudo que é dos
anos 80 vai lembrar que o médico eo
médico maluco
embora até hoje deus pais juram que
nunca tentaram influenciar bom então do
alto dos meus 11 anos mais ou menos um
ano de 93
eu tomei a decisão eu vou ser médico e
falei com o meu pai
voltando no tempo eu posso imaginar meu
pai pegando um daqueles celulares os
primeiros que chegaram no brasil
sei se vocês lembram grande você
precisava subir a anteninha subir no
telhado para fazer funcionar e acho que
ele deve ter ligado para uma família e
falou assim prepara a sala do moleque na
clínica nos oito anos seguintes sem me
preocupar muito com que as esse caminho
eu me dediquei seriamente em passar no
vestibular
até que finalmente eu entrei na
faculdade de medicina
já na faculdade de medicina as coisas
não caminharam exatamente como eu
esperava
até porque pra falar a verdade pra vocês
eu nunca esperaria nada nem parei para
pensar sobre isso
as coisas não iam bem e eu continuava
repetindo pra mim mesmo não isso vai
passar
vai melhorar só que só piorava as aulas
de bioquímica pareciam que não terminava
nunca o livro de fisiologia páginas
infinitas bom em 2003 no terceiro ano da
faculdade
eu fui assistir uma cirurgia e não era a
primeira mas depois dessa cirurgia
especificamente eu me senti muito mal
saiu da cirurgia peguei o celular que
tinha evoluído muito pouco nos dez anos
só tinha ficado menor e avisei para o
pânico geral
eu vou largar a faculdade
vocês conseguem imaginar o que as
pessoas pensaram na época o que eu acho
que eles pensaram foi mas o que esse
moleque vai ser e eu confesso a vocês
que até hoje eu não faço a menor idéia
do que você faz cinco anos depois três
coisas incríveis aconteceram uma para os
pais uma pra mim e uma para a tecnologia
meus pais eu finalmente me formei alguma
coisa bem e mesmo que não seja mentira
eu acho que ele deve ter ficado um pouco
feliz um pouco felizes pra mim eu
finalmente me livrei da pergunta sobre o
que eu queria ser e para a tecnologia
chegavam no brasil os primeiros iphones
encurtando um pouco a minha história me
livrar eu me livrei da pergunta sobre o
que eu queria ser porque na verdade eu
comecei a fazer alguma coisa e fazer
alguma coisa que eu gosto que empreender
e me livrar dessa dúvida paralisante que
era o que sobre o que eu queria ser me
permitiu caminhar e permitiu explorar
outras versões e curti muito mais nessa
jornada
e do lado da tecnologia com o iphone se
apresentava para o mundo uma nova
trajetória de evolução até então a gente
achava que tudo caminhava de uma forma
linear
isso é natural pra gente mas o iphone
mostrou pra gente
a partir dele que a trajetória é outra a
velocidade é outra é a trajetória
exponencial mas o que significa isso
eu vou voltar nos exemplos do vou dar um
exemplo dos telefones de 1993 até 2007
vocês acham que evoluíram muito
basicamente eles ficaram menores mas em
2007 com o lançamento do iphone os
smartphones
esses aparelhos que combinam as funções
do telefone com as funções de um
computador pessoal finalmente entrar no
jogo
eu não sei se todo mundo sabe mas os
smartphones já vinham sendo
desenvolvidos
muito antes a própria bn entre o ano de
93 e 94 já havia lançado o primeiro
smartphone
o problema é que a experiência era tão
ruim ea capacidade daquele smartphone
era tão o pobre que passou despercebido
era desapontante utilizar mas com a
entrada do iphone no jogo mudou
completamente a trajetória
o resultado disso não sei se todo mundo
sabe mas todo mundo tem no bolso pelo
menos duas pessoas que eu acho que não
né eu percebi mas para vocês terem uma
idéia onde a gente chegou
hoje cada aparelho desde que a gente tem
em nossas mãos
eles são um milhão de vezes mais barato
em mil vezes mais potente do que um
supercomputador dos anos 70
sabe o que significa basicamente cada um
de nós tem nas mãos o poder
computacional superior a todos os
computadores da nasa quando enviou o
primeiro homem à lua mas como por que
isso acontece o que é essa trajetória
exponencial como funciona basicamente a
tecnologia da informação ela é
desenvolvida sobre uma base anterior o
que é isso são computadores melhores
ajudando a produzir computadores
melhores ainda
o resultado disso é que a gente tem
dobras de tecnologia obras de capa de na
relação preço/performance todo ano em
ciclos que variam aí de 12 a 18 meses
ou seja é o dobro de capacidade o dobro
de potência pelo mesmo preço
ano após ano é um outro exemplo legal
a inteligência artificial não sei se
todo mundo lembra o com desapontante era
de conversar com a síria
a assistente virtual da apple é bem
desagradável na verdade só que hoje a
inteligência artificial já é capaz
existem programas de inteligência
artificial capaz de fazer um diagnóstico
de uma forma mais precisa muito mais
precisa do que é humano ou ainda os
carros autônomos que são controlados por
uma inteligência artificial tentam se
chegando nas ruas e eles vão mudar
completamente a nossa forma de viver
e tudo isso foi rápido de novo em algum
momento de discussão com essas obras as
coisas começam efetivamente a surgir e
se a inteligência artificial smartphones
são só alguns exemplos de como a
tecnologia da informação evoluir e
empurra o mundo pra frente
hoje nós temos muitos outros exemplos
edição do dna a partir de computadores
as pesquisas com materiais biológicos
para impressão 3d a energia solar
chegando a um custo muito próximo de
zero a robótica a realidade aumentada
o ponto é isso só vai acelerar se até
algum tempo se até pouco tempo atrás nós
não tínhamos tecnologia suficiente para
tratar dos grandes desafios que a gente
tem da humanidade como a saúde educação
prosperidade ou alimentação hoje a gente
está num momento único onde essas
tecnologias podem se podem se nos ajudar
nesse trabalho de tratar desses grandes
desafios da humanidade
isso é instigante empolgante não é mas
ao mesmo tempo paralisa imagina
responder essa pergunta o que nós
queremos ser então nesse contexto
aparece pra mim parece muito difícil de
ser realizado e talvez seja até o
desperdício fazer isso até hoje
além dessa pergunta sobre o que a gente
quer ser as ferramentas que a gente
utilizou para refletir sobre o trabalho
e sobre a carreira
foram essas preocupação análise
especulação a gente sabe se preocupar
sobre a vida até especula de certa
maneira mas em algum momento da nossa
vida isso já paralisou a gente faz
sentido que seja top vocês já passaram
por isso eu falo para vocês no meu dia a
dia eu tenho a oportunidade de trabalhar
com gente muito talentosa gente está
fazendo projetos incríveis e um deles na
verdade são dois dos empreendedores
o felipe eo júnior trabalhando num
projeto que é um veículo elétrico
individual projeto é demais
só que o felipe eo juninho admitiu muito
iloma ski que é o senhor da tesla e
admiram os carros autônomos que ele está
produzindo os túneis subterrâneos que
transportam as pessoas em velocidades
incríveis ou ainda o foguete que é
relançado é capaz de voltar para a terra
com grande sonho de hábito de construir
uma unidade marketing
o problema que o felipe eo júnior a
preocupar a admiração que eles têm por
pelo lance que vira paralisia quando
eles começam
se preocupar demais com que eles vão ser
e deixam de investir no projeto deles
nesse sentido qualquer meu com que meu
papel então com que minha função neste
dia a dia um tudo isso acontecendo hoje
eu apoio e trabalho com organizações e
pessoas para que elas ultrapassem essa
paralisia para que elas sejam capazes de
tirar do papel é projetar e tirar do
papel idéias produtos serviços e até
versões delas mesmas que sejam mais
relevantes nesse contexto de velocidade
exponencial e mais autênticas para elas
o que eu aprendi com tudo isso tanto com
a minha história com que o trabalho que
eu faço hoje é que a vida tem muitos
projetos pra gente
todos esses projetos são cheios de
esperança projetos do tipo de uma
realidade complexa e criativa que faz a
vida valer a pena
a vida não é uma coisa é uma jornada ea
gente precisa aprender a viver essa
jornada dessas pessoas nessas
organizações que a companhia conseguirá
ultrapassar essa paralisia eu
identifiquei três princípios principais
a reformulação a colaboração ea
experimentação
juntando esses princípios com o trabalho
de estudo e de experiências a gente na
porta da empresa que o trabalho na wii
a gente percebeu que era porque era a
gente podia criar um processo visual que
ajudar essas pessoas a ultrapassarem a
paralisia que elas conseguissem
encontrar suas versões projetar essas
versões e se começar a experimentar o
resultado desse quadro é uma imagem é
uma figura
ele na verdade une esses princípios mas
ele permite tanto a reflexão sobre a
nossa vida com atuação para quem quiser
experimentar é muito fácil essa imagem
você pode imprimir desenhar rabiscar
colocar um papel colocar na parede
a partir daí é começar e preenchendo com
seus insights com as suas reflexões
mas é importante lembrar de uma coisa
vida não é estática
então a gente precisa preencher isso de
uma vez por todas não
a idéia é que você revisa esse quadro
quantas vezes achar necessário
o lado esquerdo desse quadro ele o foco
dele é a reflexão a reformulação ea
reformulação da pergunta sobre o que eu
quero ser é do que eu quero crescer
não se trata de um destino não se trata
de definir de uma vez por todas o que
quer fazer
mesmo aquelas pessoas que falaram sou
médico você engenheiro advogado o
explorador multiplanetária e isso é só
uma visão vaga de um caminho nesse
percurso tem muitas dúvidas ainda que
continuam a reformulação é fundamental
mas para ficar mais claro essa questão
do quadro eu resolvi trazer um exemplo
pra vocês
o exemplo daqui de campinas todo mundo
sabe que campinas atrair e exporta
muitos talentos e o samuel é um desses
talentos
o samuel ainda na faculdade ele decidiu
que ia fazer uma coisa completamente
nova para a turma dele ele ia se aplicar
a um programa de trabalhos de verão no
google
o samuel não só passou esse programa
como foi o primeiro brasileiro a vencê
lo
hoje o samuel é um dos principais
engenheiros de inteligência artificial
do google
mas o legal é que ele não é do tipo de
pessoa que se preocupa com que ele é o
que ele quer ser
ele é o tipo de pessoa que se preocupa
no que ele quer crescer
então acho que o exemplo tem pode ajudar
muita gente a ilustrar esse quadro
o samuel a visão da vida pra ele e tudo
começa por aqui a gente entender que a
vida pra gente pra ele vida tem a ver
com a ajudar o mundo com esse propósito
dele mas que de alguma forma nesse
caminho ele possa curtir o caminho e
orgulhar a família dele
segundo ponto pra que aqui é importante
para a reformulação a gente entender o
que a gente qual é a nossa visão produto
sobre o trabalho com o peso do dinheiro
o peso do propósito que é trabalho para
a gente
samuel trabalho é um lugar que piquet de
autonomia permeio pra ele mergulhar em
grandes desafios e que esses desafios de
alguma forma promova uma evolução da
humanidade e ao mesmo tempo que ajuda
ele é melhorar o que ele sabe fazer
o próximo passo é definir um do que você
quer crescer para o samuel ele quer
crescendo os temas existenciais da
humanidade por exemplo a comunicação
entre os planetas
tão importante quanto reformula e
definir o que a gente quer crescer a
gente participação do lado esquerdo
desse quadro direito
é sobre isso ação aqui tem tudo a ver
com o aprendizado tanto que a gente
precisa aprender isso que a gente quer
crescer no caso do samuel é a aplicação
ele descobrir quais tecnologias já
existem hoje no mundo e podem ser
aplicadas em outros planetas
pra começar a caminhar pra aprender é
fundamental que a gente busca as pessoas
que de alguma forma já fazem ou fizeram
isso elas vão ser os nossos leitores ea
melhor forma de aprender a interagir com
essas pessoas
pode ser uma aula pode ser ler um livro
dessa pessoa ou melhor ainda trabalhar
num projecto juntos no caso do samuel
ele percebeu que essas pessoas estavam
perto dele no vale do silício onde ele
trabalha e no próprio google já haviam
pessoas explorando o tema e que ele
admirava e chamou os vizinhos heróis
ele percebeu também que muitos
cientistas já produzido já tinha
produzido o conteúdo na internet que era
relevante
então ele decidiu interagir de duas
formas com essas pessoas
ele passou a conversar tomar um café com
essas pessoas vamos à e passou a buscar
e muitos artigos na internet interagir
muito com conteúdo acadêmico caminhar
talvez seja a parte mais importante
disso caminhar tem a ver com definir
tarefas que a gente consiga cumprir no
máximo três meses
no caso do samuel ele define o que
tiraria ele dá da paralisia para ele
começar a crescer nisso era começar a
escrever artigos sobre o tema e buscar
entrar no grupo que já está trabalhando
com isso
algum tipo de projeto bom o samuel hoje
faz parte de um grupo de estudos que
está estudando como que a internet pode
ser levada para marte
ele já produziu muito artigo sobre isso
mas o principal é que ele está curtindo
demais essa jornada
ele curte essa versão que ele mesmo
chama de cristóvão colombo da
modernidade
o samuel é só um exemplo
cada um de nós aqui pode passar por isso
se você quer encontrar suas novas
versões de velas de uma forma diferente
reformule a sua pergunta
defina o que você quer crescer e que
esteja conectado com que você acredita
para a vida e para o trabalho
busque eleitores e colabore com esses
leitores para aprender
não deixe de amanhã mesmo experimentar
essa versão de você
o mundo está evoluindo demais pra gente
ser estático em oportunidades incríveis
para sermos relevantes e que a gente
curta muito mais esse caminho nós temos
muitas versões e todas elas de alguma
forma estão certas
então hoje a pergunta que eu faço pra
vocês a do que você quer crescer
obrigado
[Aplausos]